so your character it was a character
that I loved and I was very enter but I
hated and loved to hate yes exactly
yeah was that like playing the character
like that I thought it was incredibly
interesting I think a lot of the time
you are boxed into you with a good guy
or the bad guy or the me or the main
person that everyone loves or you're the
conflict driver on the side and I
thought it was a very interesting and
very smart choice by the writers to
bring in a character like Aurora that
and I think is something that they
really like to do on the originals which
is there is no quintessentially good or
bad person there are just people
essentially I always laugh about I'm
like you know they're telling the story
of humanity that everyone's from a
context and different and see things
from their perspective and no one is
fully good or fully bad we're all just
human and it's just ironic that they are
not they are the undead but it's a it's
a very human story about undead people
so what I loved about Aurora was
essentially that she she made a lot of
Dominical decisions but they told her
backstory which is such a beautiful gift
to an actor for me to even first of all
know my backstory second of all to have
been able to live it even just through
app five you know and then we had a
couple of flashes through different
episodes but it informed me so much and
it gave so much more power to the
performance and power to the drive of
the love and the the hate between Aurora
and Klaus but also her connection with
her brother and I had such a strong
point of view to every single character
like there was no water under the bridge
between anyone like everything was still
so alive and so strong so I think that's
what made her so alive and so lovable
because and also like you know she's the
bipolar a thousand year by polar vampire
like there are just no boundaries
there's no boundaries as if I a violin
as a vampire Wow this dexia there's no
boundaries as a vampire as it is but
when you add a thousand years of
suffering from bipolar on top of that
you know and her you know various issues
it's it it made her boundless for me and
thank God for the riders allowing me to
do that but and for the directors at the
time they would kind of push me in a
direction of like hoping
a little crazy but then it I was so I
was allowed to be so alive in the scenes
that you know she would and
instinctively it was great because you
know some scenes I'd be laughing where I
should cry instead or the other great
thing was in in all her flashbacks you
see the innocent human beautiful young
tortured victim Aurora who has got so
much power and love to give but is like
tortured by her life circumstance is so
much greater than her so I think when
you I got to bring that element of her
into the maniacal crazy
blood mongering killing vampire craze oh
that she was you know there are moments
where like I get something that I like
very childlike and very like she was
playing a game so I would get the thing
that I needed for this plot this part of
my plot and I would like giggle yes you
know and it's you don't often get to see
characters like that they can very often
be like you know kind of predictably
boring or they have to be sensible or
they have to like be in a box of what
the that caricature is but irori didn't
have any of that she's just like let's
go for it let's be crazy and you know so
that was really really fun and I think
that's and I didn't want to just play a
character that's like our typical you
know it's the villain to the mark.wilson
so we're all gonna hate oh because she's
the villain plotting forward the
mikaelsons story but it was like you
actually and that's essentially what she
was but because of the way I got to play
her and because of the kind of youth and
silliness and unpredictability and the
the finding the pleasure in the game of
it all I think it drew I don't think
people were supposed to like her as much
as they did you know even yeah it's just
so fun yeah and I don't think I wasn't
necessarily support I think she was
meant to be this like seductress you
know at first when they wrote her I
think she was meant to be a bit more
like mm I'm plotting things and I am
sexy and you know but as we played with
her more you know this childlike fun
really came out which really evened out
her character and I think made her very
interesting to watch and very
interesting for me to play and drew
people more so than I think anyone
expected into the like I want to hate
her and I know I should be hating her
and I know instinctively that she's a
character that shouldn't like she's
killing the people that I've followed
for the last two seasons or trying at
least
I wouldn't didn't quite get there um but
I can't help but like she's I love her
but I hate her for doing this and hey
you know especially when you have a ship
you know if you're in it really into
like Lamia yeah oh really you Clara we
had about we had about a five five
minutes on screen of like nice stuff
together and but I was rooting for it
too because I was like I totally believe
in of course I have to because I'm
telling the story I'm you know this is I
have to justify it I'm the actress but I
totally got it I was like you know that
love of your life that you find when
you're young and you just never get over
it
and you just she just loved she could
just never move on from the experience
she had with him and and I think they
really did get each other and I just
think there was just so much crap that
went down but I don't know I if they
want if the riders wanted to go that way
I could have seen totally how they could
have redeemed it sort of dark on dude
water under the bridge
okay your brother did that no way my
brother did this what total
misunderstanding let's go to dinner
you look cute you know like it could
have gone that way I understand why why
they couldn't but um you know that's
what I liked you you could believe it
happening and that made it real because
you wander into that your seat going is
she gonna can she shoot him can she
actually bring herself to kill him in
this moment and inevitably she never
could you know see it was like oh and
they do love each other and you know so
it was really alright that was a really
powerful story you know yeah just say
that her greatest desire is to be loved
and that in a way people might relate to
her easily because of that yeah
definitely I think she you know she's a
man are cool thousand-euro bipolar
vampire sure but I think that's what I
was saying before about the humanity in
the undead these characters you know is
that when you tell her backstory like I
totally get why that hurt you so much or
we are trying to get revenge or why you
and your brother would plot this like
you understand the why and I think when
you look back to her her story of her
mom dying in childbirth and just you
know that we would always blame yourself
you would always have that it's my fault
and that's something you know anyone you
know
a situation that like you need therapy
like you need some serious like let's
talk through this but you know in them
you know 980 ad you know that that
didn't exist she just left to your own
devices well I worked on my
swordsmanship that was that was great oh
that was brutal she's brutal but yeah I
think I think definitely at the end of
the day it was a really human story
about someone who did just want to be
loved and someone who felt so much guilt
and pain from the day she was born and
her father resented her because her
mother died giving birth to her and you
know she always just felt like she was
this burden on the world so of course
that would bleed into your belief about
yourself as a person and and you know
when you've gone through all that and
then you this there's this powerful guy
that sees you and loves you and gets you
you know you see each other you get each
other and you finally feel like you
found somewhere where you belong on your
understood and especially that big scene
where she's like dude where as messed up
as each other like I get you you tried
to kill your mom no way I did hey I'm
laughing I shouldn't clearly I'm feeling
this character too long I'm going a bit
crazy you know but when when they had
that moment together where they like
just got ah dude I get it
and I get you and I found a home in you
I think that was the the most free from
her burden of guilt and pain that she'd
felt a whole life and so of course she
would associate that with him forever
and you know always have that dream of
being with him because he got it you
know he was as crazy as her and I think
there's a real beauty in that you know
and there's that dr. Seuss quote it's
like you I forgot exactly what it is but
when you find the person who matches
your crazy it's like you found the one
you know I get you're crazy you get my
crazy you know I think they had that so
yeah so what's been the highlight for
you for both your character in the show
and for you as an actress of being part
of it I think I think the boundlessness
of or the playfulness of Aurora because
I've played a lot of people who are like
like me like the teenage surfer girl the
teenage kind of surfing I played like
three surf jobs in a row and
amazing but you know to get a character
that was a caricature and I've always
loved that since a kid like I was always
I've always wanted to play big
characters you know I never whenever it
was like drama class or stuff as a kid
I'd always hop in there someone else's
skin and go for it you know so I think
that was my favorite thing about getting
to do this show because it was like oh I
get to create this whole person this
whole world and I am NOT her like and
especially for me as an actress it was
really challenging because she's a
really overtly seductive person and I am
I'm not uh-huh I'm a bit like I'm just a
bit prettier I've been brought up in it
but you know I've got a very English
parents and you know you don't do that
you know I'm a good good pill girl you
know so to have to really push that part
of myself and have to really seduce a
guy on set with all these 50 other men
around um on the crew like that was
really terrifying for me but and a real
challenge so doing like that level of
sexuality but with that level of like
anger as well I don't really do anger is
like these really extreme parts of
desire and passion that I haven't really
been able to explore before because I've
been playing very human characters but
when you go to this next level and then
you bring all that those elements into
it it was a real push for me you know
there was some there were some days on
set where I remember I had to like you
know tell him don't you remember times
where we would kiss and blah blah blah
and I really struggled with it because I
had to overcome my own barriers to say
that stuff out loud to really seduce
someone so and to really want to kill
someone like obviously I've never well
maybe not only I've never had that
desire before for the record you know so
I you know to have to explore those
parts of yourself and go to be that
furious it's someone to be that hurt by
someone and to be that deranged and that
unhinged that you'll consider that that
you would plot it that you go to those
extents so yeah and and then within the
boundlessness of her sexuality and the
passion and the love and hate and then
on top of that dad to add they're like
I'm mid fight scene and I'm giggling
because it was like oh tickles that was
fun you know like oh you punched me in
the face and you
well done Haley like that was great you
know I like she gets the little piece of
thing and she's like you like this this
childlikeness coming out so so she was
just so this this world of anything can
happen so it was really exciting for me
to go to set to do that but also really
challenging because you have to do stuff
I had to do stuff that I was like oh
this is this is a push for me which is
great because you go and like with every
role that you do you hope that you go
like oh I'm bigger I'm like you're like
a sphere like it's like blowing up a
balloon and you capacity grows and grows
and goes you know so I feel like that
definitely happened with the originals
was that the question that okay yeah
yeah and the set was great to just just
on it on a more like practical
logistical level like I had to get my
fangs molded and learning how to figure
out the back you know the fang bite and
how to head back and sucking on the
blood pristine but then and it's all
made out of this sugar stuff and so I
would be doing these scenes of like
feeding or whatever and then here feel
your heart rate go up and you'd be
getting the jitters and you're like what
is wrong with me ah I just like like
ingested all this sugar through this
blood and the only way to get it off
afterward is like as its dangers with
shaving creams so after these scenes
like you know there were a couple of
your very sad scenes with Aurora where
she'd like you know hurt herself and
stuff yeah blood everywhere you just
you're just sitting there with shaving
cream just like lathering yourself off
after these scenes and the the stunts
and the rigging was really amazing
getting to do like actual fight scenes
was amazing like especially the one I
did with Riley and Phoebe I think it was
at 7 I'm gonna pair of heels and this
crazy dress and it was crazy wig on and
you know we really had to go at it and
it was it was fierce and my poor stunt
II and he's like she is not used to
fighting in heels so like the
practicalities of you know that hike on
what a high concept show demands was
like a baptism of fire for me as well
okay that you know all this blood and
how do i wrangle that and use it on my
eye and like mid take and you go flat in
your hair and then there was this one
where they had to like throw weight
class like frisbee dove sign into my
side and so they had to like make this
huge rig this like huge latex thing so
it could like look like it went in and
then I could like pull it out and I have
this weeds suit
like that stuff was really cool as well
this is a whole nother world but I
hadn't played him yet that was really
fun and especially when you dress up I
think putting on a wig and like being I
am a bat like the stuff she would wear
and then they've just um you put fangs
in it's like I am NOT me anymore
you're like transported into this person
and it and it's just really fun ritual
for me I had a similar thing I was on a
show called Holman away and I had this
like play this character called Ruby and
she always wore this like feather in her
hair
and it was like the thing it's like when
I put the feather in I'm Ruby and when I
get out it's like I'm back to me so I
got to have that with the wig and the
though craziness so take off the wing ah
oh okay the craziness is marginally
subsided now I'm just now I'm just
normal me crazy you know yeah that's
cool
all right what was your favorite well I
loved the flashbacks are five but I
think at that point Joe and I really
started still getting to know each other
we I'd only had like end of empties er
end of appetizer and of empties then
BOOM whole episode so if I got to shoot
episode 5 with the the rapport that I'd
built on set and the confidence I built
on set maybe it at black 12 that episode
I would have loved to do it again then
but I was still really happy where it
was it was part of the it was part of
the progression you know but I also
really loved the Thanksgiving dinner was
just hysterical with all the boys
because we were just like in yeah we
were just laughing the whole time that
was great but in terms of their work
that I did I think some of my favorite
stuff was actually f18 like the last
scene where I've got him chained up and
I'm just like she she I did really get
to have that like I actually even if
she's deluding herself which I think she
was a bit because when she finally got
syringe I had you you couldn't see it
very well because it was an awkward
angle but I really had this moment of me
looking at him going on oh this is a lot
as she knew she was you know getting put
under some spells she still had to look
at him and be like you you know and the
pain of that but I think at 18 she
really got to have this like what have I
been doing this whole time who even are
you like that even that
Yonsei moment is like I'm sorry what you
did what to me and I'm I'm what no stuff
you like who do you think you are and
you you these like failed seductions
like it's actually comical to me so it's
really empowering because it's been an
entire show being under his spell no
matter what under his spell no matter
what despite myself and in this final
episode it was like this full freedom of
like oh no not anymore I'm done I'm done
I'm done and she got to like kind of you
know get the power back a bit in and be
a bit more empowered in herself and not
be under his spell but I I I truly think
that it was a bit of a self delusion I
think when push comes to shove she yeah
she would still want to be I should have
pilot called Miranda's riots which is
being shopped around a bit so hopefully
that comes with something but that was
an awesome experience that was totally
different that was like lawyer a lawyer
things vampire lawyer that was great and
that was a that was a drama I love
comedy as well so I'm gonna be looking
out for that kind of stuff I have an
Aussie film I might do so music stuff
gonna be fun so yeah I think it's just
and I don't actually even know what's
gonna happen with season 4 so I don't
think they know what's happening even in
season 4 they're sitting around tables
and plotting now so I guess anything is
possible so we're just kind of seeing
where everything lands anything I'd
really I'm such a romantic like I want I
want to get the guy you know all the guy
you know I would love to have at least
it just one episode of like for me
personally for my character personally I
would like to have a roar in class to be
like water under the bridge baby like I
get it let's go to dinner and like enjoy
each other's company cuz there were a
couple of scenes like where he's taking
around the city and it was really and
they went to dinner and I don't know
they just kind of got each other I
really I really enjoyed that stuff they
can laugh together like class doesn't
laugh a lot you know so I liked that she
brought that out of him at least a smirk
at least in a Joe smirk that was its
it's a luxury it's good bet in terms of
the show as a whole I think they've
really shaken things up with their with
the characters they've you know done a
huge turnover so I I would like to see
them really focus on the immediate
family unit I don't I don't know but
it'd be cool if Rebecca came back for a
bit more
a couple more episodes I like her
popping in and out and at Daniel as well
and Casper he's really cool yeah I just
want them I I would love them to just
keep bringing in because they have a
thousand years of untold story so I
really love stuff like the streaks like
a larger being a part of that in this
club and I think that's really cool just
uncovering like this thing that happened
in ten five you know one thousand five
hundred and I don't know I think and
more crossovers with the Vampire Diaries
I think that was cool how they were
doing that you know I think the fans
loved that kind of stuff and it just
bring it just it adds a level of
legitimacy to the whole thing and really
solidifies it and makes the world really
I don't know even more real so yeah I
think they should keep I think they do
in fact I personally a little bit of
bias but I do think that season three
was my favorite you know it's just so
dynamic you know I still had all the
family stuff in there but there was a
lot of interesting levels going on so I
think they're in a really good
traditional trajectory you know - season
four yeah
you